covered the army special forces in Iraq
and masters of chaos she talked about
Special Forces operations around the
world over the last 15 years this is
about 50 minutes thanks the borders and
blend up for having us here and c-span
as well it's a beautiful day in South
Tampa and blessed to have my wife Bonnie
and boys here and some Special Forces
veterans and wives here as well so it's
great it's a great opportunity to talk
about my favorite author which is Linda
Robinson it's a privilege to introduce a
senior writer for US News and World
Report that stepped out of the box here
written a book and it's an incredible
accomplishment and the masters of chaos
Linda has captured the essence of
Special Forces better than any other
author before her and I want to thank
you from the bottom of my heart for your
demonstrated uncompromising integrity
because I've seen you during your
interviews and digging for the facts and
you're absolutely dogged pursuit of
ground truth and because of that we have
this great book today so thanks
Linda's uh lives in DC but she's been
out and about and around the world with
the Green Berets in all sorts of
exciting places she lived with our boys
in Columbia during the counter-narcotics
mission she has smelled the dust along
the border of Pakistan from the Afghan
side and she sweltered in the heat in
Iraq with the Green Berets there as well
so she has a feel for the sacrifice for
the environment for the battle rhythm
for the problem-solving and for all
those things that leap out of a leaf at
the pages out from the pages when you
read this book linden like I said don't
just capture the facts he captured our
culture and she's so persistent that she
digs and digs and digs and then pretty
soon she's under your skin and then she
does her own parallel writing because
she's in pathetic and she knows exactly
what you're doing and thinking and
feeling and all that vest on just tell a
story I mean I was having incredibly
horrible migraine headache in Cody
Wyoming but and there's Lyndon wants to
interview me with a pet bed pencil and
pad like she always does and I said I
can't stand it I can't even think and
she said no we're going to slug it out
here so that she want me to relay the
story that I told her that day and
because directly relates to the book
some folks think that the Green Berets
are door kickers and great fighters and
they are but they're also pretty wise
indirect warriors and they combine all
the elements of power of influence and
all this and come up with some really
unique combinations and one of the
themes in masters of chaos is how do you
train people to do it and we actually do
train free thinkers and we actually
recruit free thinkers work sort of a
Type B personality organization which is
very odd and a few screwballs here and
there are very good for us because it
keeps us healthy and keeps us different
well anyway the story is about snipers
in Sarajevo and and we had about 19
sniping instances and some rifle
grenades coming into our little compound
and one fellow got shot to the hand and
Tennant got grazed in the neck and this
is good to be serious and bothersome and
and and the weather was awful and there
was high-rise apartment buildings all
around of the old Soviet concrete style
and it was just a bad situation and they
were also shooting it over all of our
aircraft coming in right over our
headquarters landing at the airfield
there in Sarajevo and and we were told
to put these things out of business well
a normal combat individual would say I'm
going to kill the snipers but actually
with our French and British and other
Special Operations partners we got very
tricky and we moved some radars we could
find where folks are shooting from and
did some good photography work and all
this and that and finally one night
eliminated one sniper and and he was
illegally carrying a long barreled rifle
in the in the zone of separation which
was against the peace treaty plus other
another and other things that he'd been
doing so it took him it out and then we
did some really creative things like
sending all the fellows out with no
weapons and no helmets and all that and
passed out ten thousand teddy bears
throughout all the serve neighborhoods
never insulting a woman never winking at
a woman never making any illusion that
we were out to doing anything but
looking at children at Christmastime and
since they were Christian we were
hanging them all teddy bears that's it
that's part of it the other thing we
were doing was working on the serb pride
is the police and finally went down to
the police and captured two other
snipers without hurting them and took
them to the police and said you're in
charge of this city on this side it's
your responsibility to end the sniping
or we'll have to kill more of them like
we did the first one now we expect you
to step up the plate we respect you you
respect us let's get it on here let's
get mutual agreements get some
understanding and it's nothing stopped
so
that's indirect warfare that's using
your heart your muscle all the tools of
the trade
knowing people working cross-culture to
solve a problem instead of just going
and killing people
now sometimes that's a great solution
for allocate I'd recommend it very
strongly but there are other times too
in a more nuanced approach is
appropriate and by the way Linda can
turn a heck of a phrase because in her
book she wrote a more nuanced approach
to warfare and I have stolen I use it
all the time
and it makes my heart warm and I thank
you for that
it improves my credentials thank you
anyway
Linda surprised me with the masters of
chaos but she didn't she didn't surprise
I mean not that ever underestimate you
or ever underestimate you and yes Muse
will report but you're the first author
to capture the change in Special Forces
and the quality of our men with this new
generation this new post-vietnam
generation there have been tons of books
written about improving Special
Operations Forces soft but no one's ever
written anything about Special Forces
getting better and being a new creative
engine and I thank you for that in
addition you've you've have you not only
fashioned the definitive work on Special
Operations in the north of Iraq no one
will ever do better so those of you out
here all of you that purchased the book
today I'm telling you the parts on
northern Iraq can't be matched it's it's
world-class it's fantastic
which are fully cognizant of the nuances
of fighting the war on terror that can
serve the nation well and lend the grasp
some of these things you guys in direct
warfare and direct warfare and the fact
that you never know where you need to be
on that balance until you get involved
and then you have to adjust very quickly
and figure out how you're going to solve
the problem but it's no longer just
beating the enemy and solving the
problem and she's got that another thing
that Lynne is aware of is that
intelligence will win the war we're
talking about physical intelligence
human intelligence signal intelligence
melt but intelligence will win it and
we'll win it more than guns will and
when it and it won't just be our
intelligence but it'll be allied
coalition cooperative Nations friends
and it will all combine someday and it
will put al Qaeda and its supporters to
bed and it'll embed permanently Linda
relates to countering a global
insurgency requires two things she
doesn't say it directly but what I
gather to summarize is the intelligence
I just talked about and then wisdom and
I think that's good guidance first of
all to think the war that way and move
down that path and she appreciates that
the war is a war to change the thoughts
of billions and once you understand that
this is a war to change the thoughts of
billions then you realize the task and
you realize the administration's
statements and candidate Kerry's
statements and everyone's else that this
can't be done quickly nor will it be
easy and finally Linda thank you for
thinking that special man like my
beloved Green Berets have something
special to offer because I they do
things for that one other side now
Menten mandated by Linda is about the
length of these types of conflicts and
the changing the minds of billions and
maybe millions but when I was a young
whippersnapper in Special Forces I had a
very very good friend who was a young
brand-new lieutenant in the Salvadorian
Army he spoke perfect English but when I
went finally that his unit and joined
him he wouldn't speak English to me he
wouldn't look me in the eye and he
wouldn't have anything to do with me and
when we were forced to discuss business
it was very curt conversations and
resilient Spanish so late the evening
one evening I collared him and took him
out back in the trees and nobody knew
were there and he said it was because
his company commander was filthy
he was an abuser he was representative
of the worst of the Old South Iranian
army he didn't believe in democracy he
was part of the grande quitarse etc the
great 14 families
and all that stuff and he wasn't for any
type of progress at all and he didn't
dare risk his own career in front of
this individual but out there in the
dark we sat and had a good talk and we
realized that if we stuck with it for
enough years we can change that military
culture change their culture and make
them real and make the army realize that
the welfare of the people of El Salvador
was their primary duty and it happened
and it took 10 to 12 years but it did
happen and it did fix the problem Linda
you've suffered much with us you felt
our losses and we've buried too many men
consoled too many wives and children and
shed too many tears in the last couple
years since 9/11 yet we're not true and
America's not yet safe and my sons in
this book
John Mulholland Charlie Cleveland covo
Connors reader all of those we're still
my sons forever or in your debt for
bringing us out of the shadows briefly
but out of the shadows for at least for
a moment but for now the boys are all
going to go quietly back to work into
the dark and go fight again and fight
the enemy until we win but we'll be
awaiting the next masters of chaos will
come out in the light again one of those
days for you for our dear friend and
colleague Linda Robinson thank you
okay
when I thank general Lambert for those
words he was a little modest in his own
career description just want to make
sure that you all know that his support
with instrumental in my being able to
get this access to do the book general
Lambert was the commanding general of
the US Special Forces Command and just
assumed that position shortly before
September 11th after a long career
serving and commanding the 10th Special
Forces Group and other positions of
importance and his final position before
his retirement was as Commandant of the
US Army John F Kennedy Special Warfare
Center in school also at Fort Bragg
which is the schoolhouse training and
training center and Doctrine Center for
the US Special Forces so that gives you
an idea of the folks who are giving me
my homework as I started on this project
about a three-year long project of
immersing myself in the world of the
Special Forces and I began by reading
doctrine manuals histories the extant
literature and then was invited to come
down to Fort Bragg for some briefings
and also to attend some exercises all of
this education process went on before I
ever went downrange with the soldiers so
by the time I did I had a pretty good
idea of how the ground level units work
these 12-man teams that are the what I
call the heart and soul of the Special
Forces these twelve man teams are
literally capable of going out to
another country the ends of the earth
and operating by themselves for months
on end they also can operate combined as
a company or even at a battalion level
but the classic mode is a 12-man a team
with up to a battalion of local forces
indigenous forces from whatever country
they also work with local civilian
populations governments and both
guerrilla and standing Armed Forces
what I thought I would do is give you a
brief background of myself a brief
summary of the book and then read one
passage I personally find it boring to
just listen to people read but I wanted
to read you at least one passage to give
you a sense of the book the high
strategy level I think you've gotten a
very good view of the thinking of the
Special Forces from general Lambert and
particularly this notion that they are a
tool a multi-faceted tool where these
highly skilled and mature soldiers most
of them are in their 30s up to early 40s
they have the capacity to decide in a
given situation whether force is needed
or talking whether a unilateral solution
or joining up with local forces they
have the experience and the training to
calibrate the response that's needed in
a given situation and the reason why I
think this is so important for this
point in time is these conflicts whether
you call it guerrilla insurgency
terrorists these kinds of adversaries
operate hidden in a population blending
in with the population it's very
difficult to find them it's also very
difficult to deal with them in a frontal
conventional military-style way so you
need that kind of nuanced approach to
address these threats my career has been
as a reporter
mostly for US News and World Report my
first story was just caused in Panama in
1989 and I've covered basically what
they call low-intensity conflicts ever
since the book project began or was
critically enabled by this notion of
embedded journalists I did as general
Lambert alluded to I went down to
Colombia spent a month with the Special
Forces there and I got one of the
embedded journalist slots in Iraq in
Operation Iraqi Freedom and I spent a
total of about seven weeks
over in the theater four weeks of that
with the 5th Special Forces Group
I was also out with the Navy SEALs the
first couple of days of the war and so I
have a little bit of a compare and
contrast experience with those folks and
they comprise the larger Special
Operations community but when I say
Special Forces I refer to the Army
Special Forces that guys who wear the
Green Berets
so my experience in Iraq was quite
extraordinary I think many of us
reporters who had that chance to be
literally in a war on the front lines
with the soldiers troops of all the
services learned had an unparalleled
opportunity to understand what the
soldier or service person goes through
in the middle of war I linked up with
the fifth group in southern Iraq first
at vaaz or outside the Basra
International Airport and I was a little
concerned of my very first miscue I done
a lot of physical training I'd done my
homework to get ready to do this
assignment and I when I arrived at the
airport I camped out where they told me
to the buildings were still pretty much
intact and I was given a room where I
set up a cot and had my sleeping bag and
slept there and I got up early the next
morning and I thought well all's Quiet
I'm going to go out and and jog and get
some exercise because who knows what's
going to be happening farther down the
road so I went out and took a run and I
was after the run I was running sprints
outside there was a berm that had been
bulldozed about waist high or chest high
and one of the soldiers came out and
said we're not doing PT right now
there's a sniper line over there it's a
kilometer away across the canal so I
said of course got my stuff got together
and and from there on out pretty much I
was sitting on the back of a Humvee that
was my exercise
I was wearing my flak jacket and helmet
and the Sun was baking a lot of fluids
out of me but that was my first
introduction to the soldiers I went on
to camp with him in all kinds of places
Masseria outside Masseria and then was
sent out with different a-teams to NASA
to Courte up to the Iranian border so I
got a very close look at what different
a 12-man a teams were doing throughout
the war then when I came back and
decided to do this book I subsequently
interviewed additional soldiers and
working from that core group I'd gotten
to know I decided to write this book not
just as an account of the Special Forces
missions in the Iraq war but the careers
of these Special Forces soldiers so that
you could see the kind of experience
that they accumulate I covered since
their careers had begun either in Desert
Storm or in Just Cause in Panama that's
the starting point of the book along
with a description of the qualification
course at Fort Bragg where they earned
the Green Beret and then it follows the
book follows them through Somalia the
Balkans Operation Enduring Freedom in
Afghanistan and then the latter part of
the book is devoted to Iraq and in that
case I follow the missions in the
Western Desert which is a portion I'm
going to read to you it was really quite
an extraordinary and and I believe still
unreported a set of missions in the
Western Desert to prevent any missile
launches as well as to secure the major
airfield out in the West and the major
city aruba those soldiers were working
hand in glove with an air force wing a
dedicated air force wing and they they
achieved I would say an unparalleled
level of air-to-ground integration in
their operations which is very difficult
when you consider that these fighter
jets and bombers cannot read
locate see these 12 men a teams running
around in their tiny detachments on the
ground the northern Iraq operations
which general Lambert referred to are in
in essence a historic infiltration a
very long infiltration which was dubbed
the operation ugly baby then this really
incredible battle that was fought at the
outset of the war called Operation
Viking hammer in which a handful of
Special Forces teams went up against the
Ansar al-islam a terrorist group that
was in a an enclave in northeastern Iraq
and was found to have connections not
only to al-qaeda some of these militants
had trained in Afghanistan also Abu
Musab Zarqawi was involved with setting
up the group and had been spotted there
in that region prior to the war and this
operation Viking hammer is probably one
of their most intense combat since
Vietnam the the nine men who were on the
main effort of this attack all nine men
one silver and bronze stars for their
actions in that battle which is
recounted in the book and then finally
in northern Iraq there was an amazing
joining of the Kurdish with the Special
Forces the Kurdish militia the Peshmerga
and the Special Forces 10th group 2nd
and 3rd battalions and some from the
third group as well to go up against 13
Iraqi divisions around the cities of
Mosul and Kirkuk the third and fourth
largest cities and the oil fields there
a very historic example of what they
call unconventional warfare this classic
mission of joining with local indigenous
forces and then finally I also have a
number of chapters about the various
missions that went on in the south where
the teams the Special Forces teams were
doing a variety of missions some of them
went in quite early
to do special reconnaissance some of
them were working on targeting missions
going up to provide targeting
information for the conventional forces
that as you recall were rushing up from
Kuwait toward Baghdad and then other
teams stayed and worked in the cities to
secure them to do the stabilization to
either hunt down people who were
continuing to fight or to turn around
the cities to put the infrastructure
back together so they had a wide range
of missions there and also a short-lived
mission of setting up an Iraqi militia
which did not survive but it was again
one early example of how the Special
Forces inclination was misses their
standard procedure find the locals so
that you're not just the Americans out
there doing it unilaterally find local
forces that you can work with which i
think is a gaining currency as a way to
conduct a lot of missions we this is
essentially now what the Afghanistan
mission is and also increasingly what
the Iraqi mission is as the new Iraqi
army and National Guard and police get
trained I'm going to just read I will
open this up for questions because I'm
very eager to know here about your own
experiences and anything you would like
to know about the book I'm just going to
read a few passages about the 1st
battalion 5th Special Forces Group in
western Iraq they went in actually
before the major combat began and these
small teams their goal was to reach the
sites where they believed missiles could
be fired and also to overlook the major
city begin surveillance of the major
city aruba and in a very short order a
Bedouin had reported into a route to the
Fedayeen and Iraqi military inside the
city that there were foreigners out
about so I'm going to pick up this
passage where the Iraqis come out in
pickup trucks with the technicals
mounted the heavy machine guns mounted
on the back of the pickup trucks and
I'll read you a portion of this Oda 525
s camp became a flurry of activity in
little more than a minute the four
Humvees bull hammerhead mako and great
white - they're to hilltop sentries were
peeling out of the wadi the team leader
jumped into one of the passenger seats
and punched up Falcon View terrain maps
on his tiny laptop computer as they
bounced through the desert rubble they
turned away from their pursuers east and
then south the team made for a
finger-like Ridgeline and you turned
behind it the men set up in a hasty
ambush formation and waited expecting to
see the pursuing Iraqis at any moment
finally the four rocky pickup trucks
loaded with about 40 armed men came into
the team's view when the Iraqis were
within range of the Humvees heavy
machine guns the weapons sergeant opened
up the cold temperature prevented his 50
caliber gun from switching to full
automatic so he had to recopy it after
the first round but even the first shot
which hit the lead pickup truck with a
flash through the Iraqis into a panic
one of them tossed a rocket-propelled
grenade launcher into the air two of ODA
five to five Humvees which have been
covering the rear approach to the ridge
spun around and joined the attack the
mark-19 gunner filed it fired a hail of
grenades that enveloped another pickup
in a cloud of smoke the 50 caliber
bullets tore holes in the trucks
one truck inexplicably began driving in
circles then all four beat a hasty
retreat the Dodge quad cab the command
vehicle had not followed into the fray
but had stayed behind a call for
reinforcements as they fled the sharkman
raced back toward the hilltop hoping to
extricate their two teammates before
whatever happened next the two teammates
have been placed on a hilltop as the
reconnaissance element overlooking the
city
the chief warrant officer and a junior
sergeant are the two men
and the chief is now the focus of
attention as the chief watched the
developing scene he realized that there
was a trench line ringing the southwest
side of the city and that it had been
covered to make a tunnel like structure
with sandbags strong points the Iraqis
have been prepared for the Americans
arrival he stopped counting after one
hundred Iraqis got out of the trucks and
radioed again these guys are moving on
us if we don't get some air right now
they're going to be all over us in about
ten minutes
the chief did not think their house
their hilltop site had been spotted only
that the troops in militia were
deploying to take the high ground more
technicals lined up at the base of the
hill in what looked like preparation for
an assault the chief and the sergeant
had only constructed a partial hide site
from rocks and their camouflage nets
digging a proper hide site would have
required most of the day if the hill was
overrun they would be discovered they
set out their kit their fragmentation
and smoke grenades and extra magazines
of ammunition in preparation for a last
stand
sergeant Brittenham is down on the
ground with the other members of the ODA
he got on the satellite communications
channel that they called the air net or
the Scud net it was to be used only for
sightings of missiles or similar
emergencies but the Italian and the Air
Force had worked out codes for a variety
of contingencies Brittenham radioed the
codeword that meant if we do not get air
immediately Americans are going to die
say again the AWACS pilot asked sounding
stunned Brittenham repeated the clip the
code slowly three times
sprint sprint sprint I copy said the
pilot do you currently have any air
flying cap Brittenham asked using the
acronym for combat air patrol that's
affirmative the pilot assured him up on
the hill the young communication
sergeant watched Iraqis pouring like
ants out of the vehicles and into the
trenches and up the slope toward them he
thought to himself well thank goodness
they haven't seen us yet he looked over
at the chief who at that moment pulled
the sniper rifle up to his cheek and
began deliberately squeezing off rounds
he was using a special purpose rifle
with the Leupold scope and a suppressor
that dampens
of the high-velocity rounds it was a
weapons developed specifically for the
special operators as the chief started
shooting men about 800 meters below the
Iraqis realized they were in someone's
crosshairs Brittenham would be the
team's radio operator for the battle
from the number of armed men that the
chief was describing pouring out of the
city he could tell this was not going to
be a 15-minute skirmish he got back on
the air net we're going to need every
available aircraft you can give us for
the foreseeable future he said Roger it
Roger that the pilot responded
within minutes the AWACS had given him a
sortie of f-16 fighter jets the
immediate goal was to put enough
ordnance onto the ground to shock the
Iraqis into halting their advance so no
effort was made to match bomb to target
the planes dropped whatever they had
laser-guided je dams or dumb bombs 500
1000 or 2000 pounders in the middle of
this emergency the men worked out a
seamless close air support system that
became their standard procedure for the
rest of the war and he became the get
grab guy who talked to the AWACS to
procure the aircraft he passed them to
the marshal er the air force combat
controller who was attached to their
team who stacked the planes in holding
positions then he passed them one by one
to the chief on the hilltop who directed
them on to the targets hours passed and
still the Iraqi showed no sign of
surrendering a fighter pilot asked for
permission to go below the hard deck the
lowest altitude the planes are permitted
to fly the deck had already been lowered
to 5000 feet for this battle he was
granted permission and roared down to a
mere 200 feet off the highway as the
astonished soldiers American and Iraqi
watched in awe he landed a 2,000 pound
bomb squarely on top of the technicals
that was barreling toward the hill the
US soldiers cheered the pilot skill and
his bravery because he was flying well
within the range of the air defense
artillery that bristled all around the
city for four hours the battle continued
as more technicals and armored trucks
came out of the city the reign of bombs
from above and the team's heavy weapons
tore up the hillside and reduced
vehicles and Iraqi guns to smoking
twisted wreckage as more aircraft showed
up to join the fight the AWACS pilot
told Brittenham what was available and
he would look at the battlefield and ask
can you get us this and he would the Air
Force spared no effort or hardware in
this the war's first big fight I wanted
to read this passage partly because
we're in Tampa with MacDill Air Force
Base but it is also a tribute to both
sides they practice together in Nellis
Air Force Base out in Nevada each the
Special Forces on the ground and the
pilots above we're able to see what the
other could see how
the small Special Forces units looked on
the ground and also the Special Forces
learned what their laser target and
other signalling devices looked like to
the pilot so they had a very good system
they worked out a checkerboard where
they would turn squares on and off
depending on who was in a specific area
quadrant at that time and this went a
long way toward ensuring there would not
be friendly casualties and indeed this
Western Desert battle went without a
hitch there were no friendly casualties
and they did prevent the launch of any
missiles and the the major the company
commander in charge out there who
eventually did capture Aruba they turned
around immediately and began doing these
stabilization missions they called
together the city administrators the
military the police and they began
assigning them new tasks those who
signed capitulation agreements were put
right out to work again and the major
gym gorillas was very pleased that on
April 9th the day that Baghdad fell
Aruba already had a new mayor I think
this is a good place to stop there lots
of stories there are a lot of soldiers
here I've kind of sketched out the
various areas in Iraq where the soldiers
are stories are drawn from so I'd be
happy to tell you a few more stories for
instance the longest special
reconnaissance mission in the Special
Forces history was conducted up in the
Karbala gap that story is told in the
book although in this case the Special
Forces team decided as a whole that they
did not want their names use the only
names in the book are those that the
individual soldiers agreed to have used
and in general many of the soldiers are
either retired nearing retirement or at
least finished with their front-line
careers so using their name would not
jeopardize their families or themselves
as they would not be conducting
frontline missions anymore
also have things important just so you
know the a few of the details about
exactly how the Special Forces operate
we are not in the book and this was by
agreement I was given some basic ground
rules by the command and it's important
for them to have certain tactics
preserve them for future use and
certainly as a reporter I felt this was
a fair compromise since I got ninety
nine percent of the story and the for
the sake of preserving the utility of
their tactics I felt this was a fair
trade-off so with that I'm going to open
it up for any comments or questions any
stories that you folks want to tell
there anyone who would like to say
anything
learner yeah battle in the Western
Desert was that on the training talked
about between Nellis and the Special
Forces that kind of a base on the OE f
lessons learned as far as closed course
air support now during a rapid lessons
learned absolutely yes that that is
exactly right and while of course
Afghanistan Operation Enduring Freedom
was extremely successful in terms of a
very rapid takedown of the Taliban the
Afghan government and capturing quite a
number of al-qaeda cohorts there were
friendly casualties there were
difficulties and again it is absolutely
understandable that you have fast movers
farmers up above very high up it's very
difficult to distinguish between small
targets thousands and thousands of feet
below and also there have been some
difficulties at times using equipment
laser target designators and this
rigorous system that they worked out in
the western desert was absolutely meant
to ensure those casualties would not
recur and i think it's fair to say this
has now become a standard operating
procedure they had even though the war
in iraq occurred a year after and what
indeed while Operation Enduring Freedom
was was ongoing the units of the 1st
battalion 5th Special Forces Group had
one company that was the mounted company
they were already trained to do mobile
operations and the other company major
governesses Company actually learned
within I think it was about six weeks
obtained their vehicles because they had
been a dismounted company before so they
procured Humvees and also these strange
creations they call the war pigs which
are two and a half ton trucks that have
the cab cut off heavy weapon mark 19 or
fifty cow mounted on them
especially rigged to with winches and
cranes so that they can resupply these
Humvees in the field and this was
another extraordinary aspect of the
Western Desert operations is that you
had these two companies running around
the west being resupplied by the air
there was no one else with Special
Forces were the only ones only US forces
on the ground there and then being
resupplied by the air at night and then
working in tandem by day with this
dedicated air fleet and that was another
innovation the Air Ground coordination
was occurring at the at a much closer
level in Afghanistan they were the
control of the aircraft was coming out
of Saudi Arabia so what they did was
they brought it closer to into the
theater and were orchestrating this on a
even at the battalion level they had a
control element so there was a marriage
of ground and air like at least as far
as I'm aware really unprecedented as far
as Special Forces is concerned if
yes during the Kerry campaign was
repeated numerous times he wanted to
double the size of special forces with
the retirement age of so many of the
NCOs fast approaching and even though SF
was opened up to enlistees a couple
years ago can you really enlarge SF that
much without sacrificing the quality
this issue was discussed I felt not
nearly enough in the campaign it was
part of the Kerry campaign and while
there are efforts to grow the Special
Operations Forces generally now and
specifically within the Army Civil
Affairs and psychological operations
forces are slated to increase but with
the Special Forces it is very difficult
they have as you probably know a high
attrition rate in the try out course
very difficult to earn the Green Beret
simply because of the number of skills
that people have to have and just their
their intrinsic qualities are they are
they of the right mindset because you
can be a great soldier but maybe you're
not necessarily cut out to be this
Special Forces type of soldier the as I
understand it it is not possible to
double the Special Forces over that
short a time as was being proposed you
would have to really drop not only drop
the standards but since the bulk of the
Special Forces come from the army that's
the recruiting pool you'd have to have a
much bigger army today than then in fact
you have the initial exception program I
think is the formal name for the program
to recruit Special Forces directly from
the street they are they have high
standards they have added training time
so actually getting them through the
pipeline those that do meet the
requirements
that takes an even longer time to get
into the force and as I understand it
I think this March the first 38 were
actually placed out in the active force
the and they're continuing to do that
but in speaking with soldiers the
comfort level is to have a couple of
them on a 12-man team because there are
new even though they've undergone the
best training most rigorous training
sophisticated courses that combined
commando tactics the language training
the cultural training all of the things
that the Green Berets get their their
sere training the survival evasion
resistance and escape training all of
this incredible training that they go
through they still don't have the
seasoning that is I would say the
hallmark of the Special Forces soldier
the maturity of that soldier he's been
out especially those senior NCOs they
have been out rattling around the
boondocks whether it's you know Somalia
the goat grabs you know huddling with
chieftains of various cultures refining
their language so they know the
colloquial expressions for things also
very critical the do's and don'ts of
certain cultures that's as important as
speaking the language frankly not to
offend someone by a gesture or an action
so all of them put together is is
militates against rapid expansion which
was tried before and a lot of people
feel that would not be the route to go
what is critical is to try to retain as
many of those senior NCOs as possible
who have the 15 and 20 year experiences
at the 20 year mark many of them do off
to get out and and I have to say from a
human standpoint I find that quite
understandable these men are away from
their families and by and large they're
all family men they're away from their
wives and children months out of every
year and it's not just being deployed
for one year for one war they are gone
throughout their entire careers for
months on end
and that just puts an unbelievable
strain on the family's eye and that's
what I found in my book was the the main
thing that weighed on the men I know
that there has also been attention paid
to the contractors who are hiring away a
lot of these the private military
companies that are hiring away these men
with the super skills to do jobs for
six-figure salaries I mean there is no
way that the military can compete dollar
for dollar but they are looking very
seriously they run focus groups and
they're looking very seriously at what
kinds of incentives pay bonuses how to
feed that into the retirement because
it's keen that you not just get a bonus
but that it affects your post retirement
pay so that when you're looking at
having to fund college for those
children you can count on a certain
level of retirement pay and hopefully
they will keep they have not released
the figures for how many of them are
leaving but I think that is the critical
area to focus on if they can keep those
20-year veterans in for another five
years especially now with off-tempo so
high because I think it's clear to
anybody who reads the news Iraq is going
to take a while you know that is not
going to term terminate overnight and
Afghanistan similarly to leave now would
be disastrous and there is the ongoing
what's called the global war on
terrorism Southeast Asia the Horn of
Africa other pockets that people don't
even pay attention to that you need to
have a few Special Forces teams out
there working with the local governments
not necessarily in a trigger pulling
capacity but simply working with the
local forces and also as a kind of radar
to understand what are the dynamics in a
given country be it Yemen or Colombia or
the Philippines so I think this is
probably one of the biggest challenges
but it would probably rank as the
biggest challenge I think facing the
Special Forces right now that and
getting am
language training because there's never
enough I mean anyone has tried to learn
a foreign language especially difficult
one like Arabic Russian Chinese you know
it's just extremely difficult to acquire
the kind of fluency that you need so
there anyone else who has a comment or
question or story to tell
yes sir I mean special forces required
what is the average time from a Special
Forces volunteer starting train to being
placed on the team what's the average
time stand for that it can take the
Special Forces volunteer for the queue
course I already has a couple of years
of experience in the military so when he
his packet is accepted to try out
he enters something called the Special
Forces assessment and selection process
so there is first a winnowing out
process which is primarily focused on
the physical aspects and then they go
through what is called the qualification
course which itself has four different
phases and there they begin focusing in
on group teamwork skills the land
navigation skills very much this
combination that I find so unique in a
Special Forces soldier the independence
so that you can send him off he gets
very little guidance from me the course
the cadre that are running the course he
is he just given directions go here
travel for X number of days or hours or
go plot this course and then he gets his
next instructions at the next point so
he has to be a real self-starter but at
the same time he has to be able to work
with those other eleven members of a
team so he cannot be so much of an
independent individual that he can't
work together well with the group and
that dynamic after they go off for their
individual training which
the case of a medic it can take up to
two years to go through this cycle
because the medics actually go and train
in trauma wards and emergency rooms in
hospitals around the u.s. those
individuals they're the 18 deltas they
have wind up being able to conduct
battlefield surgery there they're highly
skilled and many of them that I met had
actually performed hundreds of
amputations in Afghanistan not
necessarily wounds that were caused
during this war but from the long period
with the Soviet occupation of
Afghanistan the land mines there had
caused amputations and since they
weren't well done or just as tissue died
they would they were requiring more
successive amputations so the full
process can take up to two years to get
through the Q course then they have
their language training and then finally
when they get through that is a period
of months so when they get through they
are then sent to their groups and in
this case some of them are being
deployed right away so it's a range
between a year and two years for the
actual training plus the language school
again depends on the language but that's
roughly correct
thank you I want to thank everyone for
coming been a great afternoon here to
spend with you and I am happy to sign
any books I know I've assigned a number
of books for you and thank you very much
for your interest in the book
Linda Robinson is a senior writer for US
News and World Report and author of
masters of chaos the secret history of
the special forces